[Music]
high-speed rail lines began popping up
in Europe and Asia in the early 80s and
passengers were exhilarated trades are
for lack of a better word sexy going at
200 miles per hour on land sounds very
exciting very futuristic politician see
opportunity for a legacy for themselves
with high-profile rollouts in France and
Japan bullet train mania was underway
and then reality set in
[Applause]
unfortunately the costs of building such
projects usually vastly outweigh the
benefits supporters who claim that most
high-speed rail systems operate at a
profit use accounting tricks like
leaving out construction costs and
indirect subsidies if you tabulate real
costs to high-speed rail lines in the
world operated a profit rail is more of
a 19th century technology we don't have
to go through these headaches and cost
overruns to build a future
transportation system what we're talking
about is a vision for high-speed rail in
America but politicians can't resist the
ribbon-cutting ceremonies and imagery of
sleek trains hurtling through the lush
countryside so the projects keep coming
don't be afraid of the future
California's high-speed rail line was
sold to voters on the bold promise that
it will someday whisk passengers between
San Francisco and Los Angeles in under
three hours nine years later the project
has turned into such a disaster that its
biggest political champion is now suing
to stop it from happening
I say we cannot afford not to pass
proposition 1a and build high-speed rail
in California it is full and it is
almost a crime to sell bonds and
encumber the taxpayers of California at
a time when this is no longer a
high-speed rail an icon of California
politics known as the great dissenter
Quentin Kopp introduced the legislation
that established the rail line and
became chairman of the high-speed rail
authority the litigation which is
pending will result
I am confident in the termination of the
high-speed rail authorities decieving
plant voters supported the bond measure
to pay for construction on the condition
that the train would be self-sustaining
according to one recent estimate the
project's latest iteration would suck up
at least a hundred million dollars in
annual subsidies the ballot measure
prohibits taxpayer subsidy and that was
an important part of convincing voters
in 2008 to a
the bond measure in the meantime
lawsuits have multiplied private
investors have fled and even the
official price tag has nearly doubled
from 33 billion to 64 billion dollars
when the legislature cleared the way for
the Rail Authority to begin selling the
voter approved bonds in early 2017 the
agency declared it a milestone cop was
livid its deceit that's not a milestone
it's desperation because high-speed rail
authority is out of money you've got to
do what you promised the voters and you
can't change that without going back to
the voters attorney Stewart Flashman has
represented environmental and
transportation groups in several
lawsuits against the Rail Authority he
now aims to stop the project on the
grounds that the agency broke numerous
promises to voters
they're going the wrong way there
they're basically doing this in a way
that is very inefficient and will not
work Farouk Feigenbaum says that
starting construction even though there
isn't enough money allocated to finish
the project is part of a deliberate plan
to extract further taxpayer subsidies
their strategy is to get enough of it
built so that basically there's going to
be so much money sunk in the project
that they're gonna argue it's gonna be
cheaper to complete it then it's going
to be to abandon it cop and flash Minh
however still believe in high-speed rail
it's just that this particular train has
been hijacked by special interests right
now it's a boondoggle I have to agree
with that and it's sad and why couldn't
they do it right because they'd made a
bunch of political promises to people
along the way we'll go through your city
oh and we'll go through your city its
winding its way around adding something
like 70 miles beyond the most direct
route since rail projects are driven
more by politics than consumer demand
nonsensical design decisions are typical
that's true even in France and Japan
where a couple of the first high-speed
rail lines were actually profitable
after building those lines both of those
countries built a bunch of other lines
that have no help of ever being
profitable not because the rail folks
necessarily wanted to build them but
because the politicians said hey city a
has rail I want it in my city Fleshman
says the California project has also
become a land grab this was going to go
right through
middle of Kings County right across
people's farmlands and we had a farmer
whose land I was going across fellow
named John toss and his name is on the
lawsuit by design
high-speed rail lines require wide
swaths of land which often means seizing
property even getting rural land can be
a problem there's a project in Texas
that is proposing to build a high-speed
rail line between Dallas and Houston and
one of the reasons why it may not be
viable is the large amount of rural land
they have to cease from ranchers
ranchers have had this land in their
family for generations they might be
growing crops on it and they're not real
interested in selling that land as for
the often promised environmental
benefits of high-speed rail
flash Minh acknowledges they won't
materialize in California ironically
doing this high-speed rail construction
with a huge amount of concrete and steel
involved is actually increasing
greenhouse gas production it would
probably take 50 to 8 years in order to
negate all of the greenhouse gases
emitted during the building of the line
California's project is extraordinary in
some ways as envisioned it will be both
the slowest bullet train in the world
and the most expensive they're using a
blend to track so it won't get to the
speed they promised because it's going
through the Central Valley it won't meet
the timetable that was laid out in the
ballot initiative it will be
conventional rail which in a way is
parallel to existing Amtrak service it
will also be competing with air travel
at a time when a new generation of quiet
supersonic planes is about to take to
the skies autonomous vehicles will soon
give passengers the same freedom to
sleep work or read as train travelers
and then there's Elon Musk's plans for
Hyperloop pod transport in a near vacuum
tube at speeds up to 800 miles an hour I
say let Alton must develop it because
I'm not advocating using taxpayer money
for unproven intestins
constants
I think if government gets out of the
way of deciding which transportation
modes we need in the future the private
sector will do a much better job of
innovating and creating profitable
transportation modes that people want to
use instead of walking in a suboptimal
choice from the 19th century
[Music]